how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
there is just a
ton of new content between marvel dc and
star wars coming out over the next
couple of years
and one of the big ones coming out next
year one that everybody is super stoked
for is the obi-wan kenobi series with
the return of ewan mcgregor as kenobi of
course
and today starwars.com has released an
absolutely
star-studded cast for this upcoming
disney plus show one that is definitely
going to get you excited for the series
and if you want to know the details on
everything that we know so far
about the series this is the video for
you now before we get
into anything if you don't know this
darth vader
anakin skywalker is returning and hayden
christensen
is returning to play him this is
obviously huge
exciting news and everybody is super
pumped about this when he went on record
talking about the show and talking about
returning as anakin skywalker he said
it was such an incredible journey
playing anakin skywalker
of course anakin and obi-wan weren't on
the greatest of terms when we last saw
them it will be interesting to see what
an amazing director like deborah chao
has in store for us all
i'm excited to work with ewin again it
feels good to be back
and kathleen kennedy said this about
hayden christensen's return
this will be the rematch of the century
so it looks like they are indeed going
to be fighting at some point in time
during the series now the obi-wan kenobi
series is going to take place
10 years after the revenge of the sith
and 9 years before
a new hope now before we dive into all
of the listed cast members keep in mind
that we could see an appearance from
qui-gon jinn
in the form of a force ghost near the
end of revenge of the sith
yoda told obi-wan and your solitude on
tatooine
training i have for you an old friend
has learned the path to immortality
one who was returned from the
netherworld of the force
your old master how to commune with him
i will teach you
so there is a possibility here that liam
neeson could return as qui-gon jinn now
besides ewan mcgregor the star of the
show and hayden christensen the second
star of the show
star wars and disney are bringing in a
huge cast for the series
two of the characters we have seen
before joel edgarton
and bonnie peace i believe that's how
you pronounce her name they are
returning as owen and buru lars better
known as luke skywalker's uncle owen
and aunt buru this is great because in a
new hope owen talks about that crazy old
wizard referring to obi-wan and obi-wan
has always had a lot of tension with
luke's family in the comics
so it'll be great to see this explored
on screen now unfortunately we don't
know who the rest of the cast is playing
as far as characters are concerned but
it is a great cast
mixed with well-known actors and
not-so-well-known actors which is what
star wars seemingly does
get some actors that aren't exactly huge
yet but the rest of the cast includes
moses ingram she was recently in the
netflix show
the queen's gambit which was really well
received by the fans
then we have kumeo nanjiani who is an
awesome choice to play a character in
the star wars universe
him being cast in the obi-wan kenobi
series is surprising but at the same
time not really because he's currently
playing a character
in marvel's the eternals so he's working
with disney already and they seemingly
thought that he did a pretty good job
with one character so had him jump over
to the star wars universe
and then we have indira varma joining
the cast and she is most well known for
her character on game of thrones ellaria
sand then we have
rupert friend joining the cast and if i
had to guess he is most likely going to
be playing a
villain he just kind of has that look
perhaps an imperial officer
then we have another big name o'shea
jackson jr
the oldest son of rapper and now actor
ice cube and he's been in some pretty
big movies like godzilla king of the
monsters and straight out of compton
then we have soon kang which a lot of
people are excited for
and is most widely known for his role in
the fast and the furious movies
in the fast and the furious films his
character is named han
and his full name is actually han solo
so it's kind of funny and ironic that he
is now in the star wars universe and
then finishing our list we have simone
kessel and benny
softdy completing the cast for the
obi-wan kenobi series now it's been
revealed today that production for the
show is starting next month in april and
the show should be coming out sometime
in 2022 but we don't have an official
release date yet but if you want to stay
up to date on all things happening with
the obi-wan kenobi series be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
videos and let me know what you think
about this cast in the comments down
below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you